joe biden has a federal judge nominee up
newsrat ciao durie and and i think in
all of the news about twitter and all of
the news about the economy some of these
really radical biden nominees are kind
of going under the radar and people
aren't paying attention you've got to
pay attention biden is pushing through
extremely radical people this woman's up
for a district court
and
she has made the claim that cops kill
innocent black men every day in america
she's made that claim in the past this
woman is up for a federal judgeship she
doesn't sound particularly unbiased or
disinterested to me
senator kennedy republican senator
kennedy came out and grilled her over
this what's even more chilling than the
claim that she the completely false
claim that she made about cops killing
innocent black men
is
the justification she had
for lying
this is a really simple question
councilman do you believe
that cops kill unarmed black men in
america every single day you said it at
princeton
senator i said it in my role as an
advocate oh okay you didn't mean it
senator i said it in my role as an
advocate to make a rhetorical point
so so when you say something that's
incorrect it's okay to excuse it by
saying oh i was being an advocate what
do you believe do you personally believe
that cops
kill unarmed black men every single day
in america senator i believe law
enforcement have an important and
challenging job in this country that's
not what you said though council
senator i say before you hear today that
i do believe law enforcement have a
difficult and challenging job and i also
understand the difference i just think
that's an extraordinary statement to
make with no data to back up
no none whatsoever
there's no basis for you saying that
and you knew it then and you know it now
how can someone possibly believe that
you're going to be unbiased on the
federal bench
excellent grilling here from senator
kennedy it's worth pointing out the
claim was not was not even that cops
kill innocent black men every day the
claim was that cops kill unarmed black
men every day which is a different claim
and unarmed does not mean innocent and
an unar a killing of an unarmed man is
not always not justified sometimes it
actually can be justified
but even that claim even that broader
claim is not true she just
lied and she admitted that she lied when
kennedy he said that statement is not
true
so ms chowdhury why did you say and she
said well that was in my role as an
advocate
in your role as an advocate you
you can lie you think that gives you
license to just lie in public well that
was i was making a rhetorical point
oh so your your rhetoric is
includes lying
no you don't you don't have any right to
lie in public
well no no but i was doing a different
job yeah you don't have a right to lie
in those different public jobs well no
no i was lying then but i'm not going to
lie now she doesn't even say she's not
going to lie now
because she's a liar and she
she i think is representing a view that
is
really common among democrats and among
the left which is at the end justifies
the means
which is that yeah you can tell some
lies if the lies are going to get you a
good end well yeah when i was in this
job i i wanted to get this political end
so i said this thing now that i'm going
to be in this judge job i'm going to say
a different thing but you know we're all
just trying to get to the same place
if
if our elected officials have no respect
for the truth then we are completely
sunk
and and
it's even broader it's even within our
whole society if our society has no
respect for the truth then we just can't
govern ourselves if we're moving from a
society that acknowledges objective
reality and objective truth to a society
that denies objective reality and
objective truth and only only exercises
or only claims subjective truth my truth
and your truth subjective identity my
my gender identity my ex gender
expression my oppression my my my
then we can't communicate we ha there
has to be a reference outside of us that
we can point to we have to be able to
speak the same language and the words
that we use to communicate need to refer
to real things outside of us in order to
communicate in order to get along
together in society if we don't have
that
all that will ensue is chaos all that
will ensue is anarchy and we're not just
talking about the hoi polloi who are
engaging in this dangerous political
game
we're actually not we're talking
specifically about the elite i bet that
woman went to some of the fanciest
schools in america boy she has the
arrogance that only a top ivy league
credential can give you the way that
she's the way that she brazenly boasts
about lying
the way that she's she's just sitting
there so giving such glib answers to
this senator and what she is saying is
truth doesn't matter
what is truth
what is truth no that was just my
rhetoric it's the line that pontius
pilate said to jesus christ at the
passion
he says what qui
veritas what is what is truth what is
there no there is truth and if there
isn't truth then we're then we're really
sunk in self-government
but that what the libs try to do
is when they get caught in these lies or
when they get caught in a tight
political situation one of the ways that
they deny truth is they just redefine
all the words i'm glad you liked that
clip now
ding ding ding ring that bell subscribe
get all the notifications for the
michael knowles show you can also head
on over to apple podcast spotify stitch
or google play wherever you get your
audio podcast subscribe to the michael
knowles show we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]